am i going to every week you know
wanting to take a quarterback soul you
know you get to look at the mass I see
fear in his heart that's when you know
you got him so on that's how you know I
played a game and that's how we're gonna
do to the game the Marcus Lawrence
talking about Jared Goff you know most
of our our estimations of Jared Goff
went down after the Bears game right and
then they lost to the Eagles all week
and we you know we were talking about
whether its Jared Goff talked earlier
and Donald one of those guys being an
MVP candidate and I think well I know
golf and Gurley really subsided late in
the year as they did Ken Gough get it
back against a defense like Dallas
of all the defenses out there in the NFC
this is the one you don't want to fake
right no you're exactly right I mean
it's a Super Bowl defense with the
Dallas Cowboys have there's no weakness
I mean they match up on the defensive
side of the ball really well with the
Los Angeles Rams
you know the Rams at least got some
confidence going at the end of the year
by beating the Cardinals and beating the
49ers you know to maybe get their mojo
back but I would also say come on it was
the Cardinals and it was the 49ers who
weren't playing for anything at all at
that point with Nick Mullens at
quarterback but again it's sean mccabe
week off it does seem like Girly's going
to be somewhat of a factor we don't know
totally what he's going to be but when
you look at woods Robert woods cooks oh
you know what's on the other side shidou
be a lose a Byron Jones maybe the best
cornerback duo in football and just like
we always talk Mike with about any great
defense the Dallas Cowboys can get to
the quarterback rushing for consistently
and we saw some cracks in the armor with
the Rams offensive line down the stretch
against the Eagles and the Bears and
those great deep title exactly right up
the middle that is very concerning and I
think hey when it comes to playoff
football it is all about finding the
mismatches and if the Rams getting some
obvious past situations the Cowboys are
to do their best to get it - Marcus
Lawrence singled up against the right
guard or the center who struggles in
pass protection I see this being a
really close up ballgame
I think it's physicality versus yeah yes
yeah and I think the Cowboys are going
to hit them early and they're gonna
rattle them and and I feel like for the
rim you know is this charmed team until
54-51
in the aftermath of that win over the
Chiefs right into their bye week you've
talked about how the bye week can screw
a team up baby does it kind of exhale
they had Thanksgiving on the by wickets
and then y'all wait we still have games
to play right let's just fast-forward to
the postseason though it's not that
simple and now you're struggling to get
it back and I don't know that they can
get it back especially with Gurley he's
missed a couple of regular-season games
it's troubling that the knee is swelling
up without any obvious interaction right
and and is he gonna be able to play the
whole game what are they gonna be able
to do and if you're the Rams defense
yeah how do you avoid the Cowboys just
pounding the ball pounding the ball
pounding the ball especially if they
take Aaron Donald away yeah who steps up
on that defense I mean that's gonna be
the million dollar question you're
exactly right and you know you know the
one thing they have in their favor at
least to maybe slowing down the run and
I don't expect them to be able to slow
it down much because I do think since
Marc Columbo took over as the offensive
line coach for the Cowboys you know
they've been pretty good and creative
and finding just some few things every
week on how to run the football on
defenses and we know the Rams are not
good at stopping the run we know that
they're aggressive they fly upfield it's
great for a pass rush but it's not
necessarily good for run defense so that
that is trouble but you know you have a
week off with Wade Phillips and the the
other thing I'll say just for maybe Rams
hope here is the Cowboys offense their
pass ovens we know it's not overly
complex you do have these corners and
Peters and a keep to lead I do think
though at times we'll be able to put
their defense in the you know their eggs
in the all let's stop the run basket and
be able to play some man-to-man at
moments because they really only have to
worry about Amari Cooper who's scary and
the scheme itself does not expose
man-to-man coverage a whole lot in
Dallas so that's where I would say the
Rams have a chance to maybe slow it down
to degree but I do think the Cowboys are
gonna use the old formula love pound the
rock keep that other keep that other
offense off the field with an occasional
big throw from dak Prescott who's played
very well down the stretch you know the
Rams are in danger of becoming the NFC's
version and Cincinnati Bengals yeah yeah
because you've got the great regular
season but you can't deliver in the
varieties and then Andrew Wentworth is
the common thread he was with the
Bengals for those five consecutive one
and Dunn's now he's looking at possibly
two straight one
Duns with the LA Rams and I think that
it makes it so much harder the next time
if they do lose this one never gets real
anyway look at what it does the Bengals
every time the beg was in the claps and
just crank it all the way up yep and and
that's gonna be the knock-on McVeigh at
a time when McVeigh has a coaching tree
hey what's he done to merit it other
than have great regular-season success
he needs to have some postseason success
and we'll see if he can he can prove yet
again that he has abilities beyond his
years yeah cuz this is gonna be
everything he can handle and you know I
thought about the the Chiefs game the
Monday night game it had a playoff feel
to it in the Coliseum maybe this helps
them yes but when they come out of the
tunnel oh it's not gonna feel like a
home guy I mean right I mean what do you
what do you expect in crowd 20 60
Cowboys 40% Rams if if that many rams
you know I'm with you I would say I was
up as moments ago 70/30 Cowboys things
because you know there's a ton of them
in the Southern California too so III
know it's not gonna be a home-field
advantage certainly and then you talk
about you know okay this all the things
McVeigh like should do creatively you
know scream game bootlegs all those
things and it's gonna be tough against
this Dallas defense when you got a guy
like Jaylon Smith and Vander Esch at
middle linebacker they're a phenomenal
sideline to sideline they match up
really well with the Los Angeles Rams
it's gonna be can the Rams score points
and what we've seen the Rams defense
that's bailed them out all year Mike is
they just make that timely play in the
track games rights right so that's what
we I think it comes down to we're gonna
I think we could sit there all game and
go man the Rams defense is getting their
butts whooped
but Aaron Donnell got a strip sack and
the biggest play of the game and that
you know swung the momentum that that
way that's what the Cowboys have to stop
the Cowboys have to worry about Connor
Williams against Aaron Donald that would
be the one thing I would say too when
you have to double Aaron doc you do it
and hope that the rest of the game you
don't get obvious you pass situations
exactly right it does that's good that
could be trouble
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports